welcome back folks that was the e a
press conference now let's talk about it
ah kicked it off star wars battlefront
not hard line as we thought in fact that
was quite an ending to harm I don't get
we'll get to that soon cuz that was I
thought that was awesome but uh let's
you know kick it back into the things as
possible we went through it again star
wars battlefront here we are seeing a
look at a sort of creator diary kind of
thing that they gave us and was there
like a teaser of footage there is a land
here like a speeder bike tut yeah toward
toward the end there we saw the moon of
Endor speeder bike footage and I can't
be the only one who got a little bit of
goosebumps going on once they saw like
that that footage there that low it is
very cold in here you're right oh yeah
it's also very chilly you see a little
bit of health on one of their screens as
well yeah but yeah I mean like it's
there's quite a few uh early concept
early an engine like it's it's very
obvious right yeah yeah yeah yeah that
doesn't look girly to me that looks
amazing but quite all of that stuff is
sort of like look this is early it's
still gonna be a long way away but it
still looks really good yeah so see more
spring 2015 is what it said yeah that
mean like we'll have a trailer to show
probably fall 2016 is one this game is
coming yeah yeah I mean certainly if
it's looking like that well who knows
that's exciting though there's a little
bit of hot as ever mentioning Kevin do
you think I think they're gonna make
good on their you know 8080 take down
the orgo I would like them to I don't
know like I'm having a hard time getting
myself pumped about anything except
battlefield at the very end and even
then I don't know like there's a lot of
talking there was a lot of like hey
we're gonna tell you about here's here's
interview with creative people and we're
gonna do our little our little
documentary style thing but we're not
just going to talk a lot not really show
you anything it was a kind of drama talk
with lots of hyperbole and intense there
was a lot of buzz word going on today
never before have you ever this
experience had for the first time ever
in the history of history all right so
we have that quick battlefront thing
then we got into dragon age inquisition
which I that King just looks so
beautiful in the stuff that they're
showing it's gorgeous it was great to
finally see some actual gameplay as well
and not just environmental fly throughs
which is really all we've seen up to
this point yeah but you know this is
really reminding me of Dragon's Dogma
actually just the way that's like right
down there and really active and
everything's you know sort of going on
at once mm-hmm they're targeting a
specific spot on the dragon here the
front right leg and yeah like you know
lots of these sort of particle effects
around the different skills and they
were talking about you know they're sort
of showing off the range of powers that
you've got available in this in this and
the Dragon Age games Kevin what did you
make of the Dragon Age showing it looks
really good right but I think the most
the most interesting things that they
made sure to give a nod i think to pc
players in particular at the end by
mentioning the top down camera you know
view to make sure that people knew that
you were still going to get the you know
pause and consider gameplay that people
kind of want to tactical right yeah yeah
because i was in the first game but it
was not in a sec not on the second game
um yeah but now it's on all platforms
that camera so yeah nice and consistent
yeah so that's that's good news for
folks that like that aspect of Bioware's
rpgs and for folks that like the
environmental fly throughs were going to
well we had one of those but now this is
like the character real intro right I'm
sort of giving an idea of these
different people here she's doing that
gladiator walk through the wheat thing
and this dialogue was that the voiceover
for this section was super cheesy it was
a so cheesy bad oh my god they had like
a few sentences to explain everyone's
origin yeah odd not to make it sound
kind of contrived and stereotypic so
much has been done but this guy you know
like he can take on anything except for
the life he left behind at some point I
mean what do you even do because also
this is sort this is set in like a high
fantasy setting and so you know you can
only you can't like get real irreverent
with it or anything right so you know
that that dialogue aside you were
getting a glimpse of these characters
and of course
the whole party you know system and the
the different characters you get in
dragon age has always been such a
driving force for the the character of
that story and for the plot for player
investment I you looking forward to any
of these any playing with any of these
characters oh yeah absolutely and that's
something that you know dragon age has
always been really good even when it
stumbled with dragon age 2 is that the
relationships between the characters in
the game has all have always been really
good and they felt very real the
problems with dragon age 2 I don't think
were so much with the characters no they
really wasn't what I want to know is is
the cellist gonna be a playable care the
most important thing none of the mag
eres unfortunately so no yeah pre-order
for the cellist party member to stand in
the corner of your cabin in heard power
stance and just let rip chelis DLC haha
it's coming you know it dragon age
inquisition looking quite pretty during
the e a press conference and then after
the dragon age we went on to the mass
effect and i said before the show i was
gonna be pretty happy if they did
anything mass effect unless it was the
HD thing so you're not really that happy
I'm kind of happy I mean this you know I
wasn't I guess in my heart of hearts not
expecting anything super tangible me
this looks like more of a trailer for
Casey Hudson than from a suspect yeah
that could those are those luxurious
curls wonderful perm which is just
really on point look at that look at the
light fascinating across those curls
they just it just captures the his
essence really so a lot of conceptual
prototype and that was a phrase we saw a
couple other times during the press
conference but you know the part where
he's sort of saying what if you could
just go to different worlds and like
what if you went beyond those worlds
that's kind of me kind of the appeal of
mass effect right you've always been
able to go too far off world and go
beyond you know so what you so exactly
what does it mean you know we're making
some new world it's not just gonna be
you know I think what a maintenance to
bring back more of like that sort of
Mako exploration where you drop down on
this unfamiliar terrain and you're sort
of like where do i go i'm just going to
drive off somewhere and try and explore
because two and three so to drop you
into these car
it was like this very linear sequence
once you were actually on a planet yeah
absolutely but the downside with one is
that you always went to these places
that were still more or less the same as
all of the other places and all of the
buildings were the same building short
and there really wasn't anything to
explore for nobody it felt like you were
exploring well that's what they've gotta
fix they've got to get that feeling back
and give you a reason to do it again
yeah give me places to go and do you I
mean you know these are prototypes of
different worlds do you see them may be
working in some kind of procedural
generation to create these new worlds I
mean that's certainly something to see a
lot of games experimenting with more and
more as we have the new consoles and you
know PCs and just systems be more more
powerful being able to I think if they
want to do something crazy like let's
have you land on every planet they would
have to do that but by where is I think
the kind of studio that loves it's
handcrafted content and I want to make
everything you know as snazzy as
possible so I don't really see that
happening I think bioware is really more
about the the smoke and mirrors and they
are about you actually giving you a huge
thing like they give you the impression
of something that's huge but don't
actually deliver the hugeness so i don't
i don't know that this is actually going
to be that much but there they promised
right in there buzzword heavy
introduction that it was going to be so
much grander than we could possibly have
imagined and and one phrase they used
during one of those documentary style
vignettes was we're entering a new
generation of bioware games where all of
our games are going to be these big open
worlds so I feel like whatever it is
that they're doing with dragon age
inquisition they're going to try to
apply that more to the Mass Effect
framework yeah and lets you know they're
talked about their games they also
talked about a new IP in development at
one of their studios I it's sort of as
big as the Mass Effect world but they
want to tell contemporary stories modern
setting yeah so but you know more modern
than mass effect still gives you a lot
of leeway I mean it's at five years in
the future is it on earth planet or is
it something analogous to earth
battlefield RPG
we did see some action cider all this
affects really in the future right so
you know but contemporary story of the
phrase right so like if you're imagining
you know that to indicate something
that's not thousands of years in the
future it could still be a few years in
the future could still be fantastical in
some ways but it implies certainly a
more modern sensibility but it really
could be anything I mean we don't know
anything truly about this game animals
to the point where why would you okay
sonu unannounced game from bioware at
the end and at this point you know what
they know about it might change entirely
or just because of the nature of game
development the sims 4 as expected Kevin
it just blew up your whole a notion of
what the sims is that all everything's
changed now it's a whole new world if a
blue dress really silly and having
strange thoughts about the world and
their elderly neighbors was the darkest
moment of the press conference actually
I think it just took a real really lost
it was the narrative they laid out this
guy Chuck he's like uh he's a hothead
he's he's a con man a real hothead but
he tries he's also a bit of a romantic
does he like he tries to initiate this
like made December romance with Gladys
that's what I got from it is that what
actually happened I think so well it
didn't happen in the end but yeah that's
what he wanted she wasn't having it she
wasn't like no and then oops he died mmm
he was throwing a party to cheer himself
up and he died he died that's worth
which is a lesson from EA that you
should never try to cheer yourself up or
you will die I don't remember my sims
ever being that vulnerable before I mean
I've killed sins before or mainly when I
like have them go to the bathroom and
then I take the doorway so they poop
themselves as oh yeah where you just
like put a lot of heavy curtains around
the stove yeah and the whole place goes
up and we take the letter out of the
pool yeah yeah so die nobody knew he'd
have a lot of business
yeah but they're talking a lot about
like you know emotions and communities
and they do but like the emotions you're
seeing our cartoony and exaggerated and
until they still do that to sort of
convey exactly what that is yeah it's
really weird though because I'm I'm
still wondering what is the substantial
change over the sims 3 and through all
of this there's nothing that really
stood out to me as oh this is a
substantial change you've never seen
this in the sims before so I'm sort of
curious like the one thing that they
really got to at the end was now you'll
be able to import other people sims not
just the physical aspect of their sim
but the entire emotional aspect of the
same as well so I'm sort of curious like
is it like that's my big takeaway from
oh this is the thing that's really new
new but nothing else about this
presentation really says to me wow the
sims has really come a long way let's
sort of hinted of that kind of like
SimCity like connectedness between
players but didn't really explore where
I said more of that right but to people
even want the sims to be new new well I
mean I think people want I you know
there comes a point though where it's
like you know you want something that's
familiar but even the expansions have
gone to the point where you're actually
doing really interesting new things in
that universe yeah so i'm really i'd
really love to see the sequel like what
is the sequel bringing me that is
something that i haven't yet well the
great rape as a tablet now so that's new
yeah that's that's true that is new and
i noticed that this uh this young lady
has a like she likes to sing yeah yeah
as President Obama is also in there for
some reason thanks Obama all right the
sims trailer concluded on the darkest
note of the e a press conference as a
Chuck died r.i.p Chuck and then we went
right into dude hell of punching other
dudes UFC yeah playable worsley yeah one
man punching a dead man and then
eventually got knocked out cold yep that
was a so what do you make Chris waters
I'm asking the questions no no no I'm
gonna turn the tables on you how do you
feel about Bruce Lee being a victim of
virtual violence in a
video game I think we've seen I like
with with boxing game in the past I
believe we've had sort of like play as
the legends huh and I don't think you
know these sort of the fantastical
nature of video games lets us experiment
with these with these essentially what
you know Bruce Lee is as real here as he
is you know no that's not gonna as he
was racing as he wasn't you watching a
movie he's as real to you then I was
gonna say you're interacting with him in
the same way but that's not actually
doesn't really make any sense yes he was
acting in the movie he didn't like mocap
for UFC but no I do like this kind of I
you know them sort of delving into the
the history of this kind of fight and of
the stars of martial arts and you know
is it gonna make a big UFC fan out of me
I don't know I'm just glad we finally
got a hug you know yeah touch and go
from one more advanced warfare actually
but yeah I'm just kind of worried that
they're going to have a what was it
Activision and Kurt Cobain situation
where they had a whole lot of legal
trouble with him playing other people's
songs yeah is much more his likeness can
ya come in there but it doesn't look
like you know Bruce Lee's estate cos
gonna come after them cuz Bruce really
wasn't a ground-and-pound kind of guy
sure yeah oh I just want to see the
knockout blow because it was pretty
amazing when a guy just slumps down dead
onto the ground the ending of this demo
felt a little bit like the ending of the
battlefield hardline demo which is like
of course you have to have Bruce Lee
knock this dude out yeah he's not
exciting arrest the robber yeah the end
of that demo yeah all right come on
Bruce yep stick it to him yeah you just
fell over like an action figure is that
an animation or is that like euphoria
physics just taking care of that you
know I think I don't think that's fully
animated there's something there's
listen Whitney Cathedral they're going
on we need to mocap you getting not too
cold on your feet get ready yeah all
right we moved then through these fight
the sports stable a little bit more unit
went to NHL 15 which looks like the
gorgeous incredible hockey simulator
that it has been for many years running
yeah anybody feeling passionate about
discussing the Hawking
well Dan is an Australian who's really
into hockey yeah what are you uh you you
hit the puck yes I know it's your buck
yeah not a bowl the GATT is accurate the
one thing that stood out to me during
this is they focused on the crowd every
so often here and then and in a few
times elsewhere and I just kept thinking
why are you focusing on the crowd which
is still so clearly the weakest part of
the reason it's the one thing they're
able to slightly upgrade every year so
it's like yes we better crowd I I guess
I guess so but it's funny because I
would actually have been focusing on the
players and how incredible these you
know the hits feel and and and and so on
and so forth but they keep showing the
crowds and it it's fakeness just really
stands out every time yeah I wanted to
see an actual match from a player
perspective not these kind of like
cinematic quick cuts actually but they
don't do that I know Kevin the crowd is
you the crowd today I want to tell you
that they're animating you true to life
now and you know all the chance and all
the songs like a true hockey fan there
are there even hockey songs yeah yeah we
are take me out to the ice rink haha
kind of a reskin of an opposite knock
you out yeah mama said knock you out
yeah and all the greats know the great
yeah another one bites the ice yeah
exactly yeah all right you're you're
foolish for even asking Oh teeth ice mmm
all right one of the games we were
really looking forward to or the
announcements we were looking forward to
for the a press conference of course was
the New Criterion game and we saw that
one and there was some speculation that
it might not be a racing game I come on
it's a racing game and you know it is it
a helicopter racing game yes but also
jet skis and ATVs and helicopters with
ATVs attached to them and wingsuits and
parachutes and basically a whole mess of
different extreme conveyances yes I
think Andy Baumann said it best when he
said are they making GoPro the game Yeah
right there was some GoPro shots in
there but yeah you're there you go
there's your others boats personally I'm
excited about the wingsuit because
by three exactly because wingsuiting in
Far Cry 3 was absolutely wonderful I
don't know why you know there's
airplanes in here this is like pilot
wings extremes so this little studio
tour thing kind of ties into a question
that I had in the pre-show which is
they've whittled down criterion as a
studio so much like what do you do with
that studio name now and they're jumping
right on that saying all right we're
really small and nimble it's like a it's
like a startup culture we don't have pre
assigned desks we all sit near each
other sometimes we go to the pub and
they're like they're trying to own that
which is an interesting strategy as far
as I'm concerned they didn't get a name
no mmm and that's called a prototype
game plan but I became too i'm not
mistaken yeah conceptual pro total lot
of the game actually over the course of
the press conference surprisingly i have
a prototype gameplay the game mm-hmm
mmhmm yeah so you know is that does that
sort of diversification of racing
mechanics i mean i've certainly i love
the burnout series and really enjoyed
the kind of crash modes in that and it
sort of seems like it it lends itself to
a more freeform game situation or some
more like open-world type yeah it looks
like I went so much racing us or just
being in a sandbox in all these
different crazy vehicles and I'm not
really sure how that works with like get
from A to B but pick whatever vehicle
you like and how does that be fair to
everyone you know to get to answer that
question played diddy kong racing all
right one of the biggest shouts actually
that erupted in the game spot room
behind us here during the EA press
conference was during the PGA Tour demo
which one really thing and I went to a
real weird day you know golfing you know
they did say it was golf without limits
rah so I heard of golf with limits you
know just gong show limits is just
hitting a man with a golf club but then
you know you're playing this course and
then all of a sudden the next drive is
taking place in paracel storm a map from
battlefield 4 during the LEvolution
event where this destroyer runs a ground
cut loose from its moorings I mean this
happens in battlefield multiplayer games
and that was a PGA Tour I wish I would
just give anything to be a fly on the
wall in the e a creative meeting where
they said all right guys we lost the
tiger woods license and what are we
going to do we gotta jazz this up
somehow what do we got and then an
intern in the corner of the room goes I
have an idea battleships sprinkle some
battle yeah we were joking before in the
pre-show about the battlefields gonna
get putting everything but I think any
of us picked it was gonna be don't you
and you know I'm totally on board with
it too because golf games have been done
since time immemorial you know it's been
around forever why not do something just
[ __ ] crazy and insane so yeah I mean
what you know it's don't go full hot
shots golf with it cuz that snitch is
already established but take the
mechanics you have take that like
realistic sim thing and make essentially
a fantasy mini golf course right only
real golf yeah yeah delightful
delightful Oh God there was no
battlefield in Madden there was a new
blocking circles and tackling circles
that sort of allow you as a defensive
player to do a little bit more finagling
to to position yourself better they
talked about different types of tackles
for example aggressive tackles yeah
timid tech conservative tackle uncertain
with oneself tackles really really you
know considering considering has life
choices tackles section of tackles
phoning it in because you're one month
from retirement tackles overeager but
perhaps not quite on point tackles yeah
hungry tackles uncreate hungry tackle be
tackled that was a hangry tackle right
there hangry hits have you actually is
the hashtag that they were promoting
yeah Oh Matt and I looking looking like
you know these these games at ease
pressure options they always look fresh
they always look new they always make
you feel kind of bad for the people who
were enjoying the games they made last
year love it like got to hear about the
other side of the ball well yeah the
other side
other side of the ball the part where we
tackle it all right so we went from
madden 15 into a game that we mentioned
earlier on dawngate they showed off
their MOBA MOBAs are hard to show off
they did like these developer interviews
they did you know sort of showing people
at events the things the developers was
saying were absolute monsters it was
stuff that applies to every moba and
they weren't saying anything really that
was significant about this beyond what
they were saying about the story and the
maps be I thought of it narrative yeah I
think when they yeah when they touched
on the maps being tied to the narrative
that was the only thing that had any
real substance to it because everything
leading up to that was we're really
listening to our community we don't want
to make a MOBA like the other MOBAs we
know that we've got to do something
different but there were no specifics
for like the first three minutes in the
video and it was pretty lengthy but
we're gonna move on from it anyways
because I talked about mirrors edge
let's get right in there this is you
know again conceptual prototype or
whatever the the tag was they were
putting on here because they work it was
basically another sort of dev interview
kind of situation we don't the game is
still very much in early stages of
development it's interesting because the
trailer they showed last year looked
much further along than what we saw here
so I'm wondering how much of that was
kind of funny and and this is sort of
what they actually have in you know live
gameplay mhm this was just so ultimately
like yay more mirrors edge boo we don't
know crap about this game anymore than
when we started and that's the thing
that's really disappointing to me it's
like it's still a bunch of documentary
shots and then a bunch of stuff that
basically you could have just applied to
the original Mirror's Edge i disagree i
think that what we saw was really sort
of subtly tweet from how Mirror's Edge
one worked it's far more aggressive and
far more fast paced these kinds of
takedowns happen a lot quick up and we
never saw her actually pick up a gun
which is really refreshing well that is
I mean that is nice I guess I just don't
know that I got much out of this beyond
me a mirror said I didn't need to say
we're doing Parker
yeah look at that dude use did a flip
come on doesn't like flowers yeah yeah
nicely done but even then here we see
what's obviously you know placeholder
elements and just you know you've just
got the the colors in place and it looks
very very similar to mirrors edge which
you know this mirrors edge which is also
mirrors edge it is trying I guess that's
a good thing and I don't know it looks I
mean it looks I mean you're right in the
sense that it looks more fluid like when
she's moving it does appear that the
they sort of transition into each other
a lot better but it's just so hard to
know what what is what is this game
beyond yeah or more me I really hope
they keep the up button and down button
control scheme is that just worked
really well I think alright well that is
our look at mirrors edge here and then
we saw some fifa and for more gamespot
coverage of fifa you can follow at Danny
O'Dwyer we're going to go right into I
think now battlefield hardline that was
by far the most substantial showing
during ea's press conference obviously a
huge focus for them as it's coming out
later this year and they ended on that
big note the beta but let's talk about
the gameplay demo and how they set it up
and what you guys saw dice is amazing at
choreographing live multiplayer gameplay
demos and it's funny because no actual
public match plays out like that no one
is that coordinated it's never going to
be that cinematic and that cool and that
fluid but it still gives you a good
sense of what the mechanics are and what
they're introducing a thing yeah I think
that the thing is you know it all strung
together is unbelievably choreographed
when the great thing about the
Battlefield franchise has been and it
looks to be here again is that you can
get snippets of that you can get like
you know tens 10 awesome seconds in a
row it comes together and it's
incredible and the fact that it all
happened that way is unlike any other
game you played you know not this Martha
taking cover but you are you know you're
there breaking in doing some you know
what looks to be like really ineffectual
SMG shooting but this is sort of
everyone converging in this mode which
is you grab I believe
is this the neutral loot now this looks
like a two anyways the game mode there's
more game mode discussion in depth on
gamespot we actually have some hands-on
previews that you folks can read there
once we wrap up here which will be in
just about five minutes but I let's talk
about battlefield hardline and the
impact it made here did you you know do
you think that they have suffered at all
from the leaks or do you think this is a
good excitement generator I think this
is definitely good excitement generated
because you know we didn't see anything
like this I think they're you know quick
cut cinematic single-player scripted
moment trailers aren't really what we
want to see it's this kind of stuff yeah
absolutely and the stuff that leaked
that was like you know campaign story
sizzle reel kind of stuff and this is
you know it's obviously very heavily
choreographed but it is multiplayer in
engine gameplay and you know I actually
got to play a couple hours of this a few
weeks ago and you can read my hands on
impressions on the site right now but it
has a lot of this sandboxie kind of like
payoff moment kind of stuff where you
know you'll spend five minutes row five
minutes in a row getting shot and killed
a whole bunch of times but when
everything comes together and clicks you
have really cool stories to tell it's
just they cram all those stories
together really closely here it's not
that this isn't you know early alpha
gameplay footage as well this is
actually what's going to look like yeah
and you saw a little square button
prompt here so obviously this is
playstation 4 footage that they're using
so much levolution as well yes yes
absolutely we saw that crane falling
down we saw a support pillar followed
collapsed just there and one thing I
will say about the levolution those
particularly with that yellow crane that
we're going to see toward the end of
this demo is that unlike a lot of the
stuff in battlefield 4 which is just
window dressing like stuff happening in
the distance like that crane actually
creates a bridge between two objective
points in certain game modes so yeah it
totally changes the Berkeley that willow
crash the server so does that mean
you're my only priority for a specific
team or you know like is it advantageous
to both did you get a sense of that
during your time yeah I mean it's fairly
neutral so I don't think there's really
any incentive the only incentive I can
think of is that there's a ladder in
that crane that you can spend about
eight minutes finding up so it's good
for snipers too
get up there oh yeah if you want to
eliminate recon threats or I think
they're called professionals now not
recon okay but yeah it uses the same for
class archetypes but if you want to get
rid of that that perch you can just
knock it down and then the professional
will have to find somewhere else to
grapple hook up to to find that person
yes we're gonna see actually right now
some professional work as they do that
that's switching sides which I thought
was a really clever way to present oh
yeah the action yeah but this you know
one in a million like timing right and
headshot like but at the same time those
shots happen and that's what makes this
series so beloved it's a riot shield
their ethic yeah so right shield is one
of the little gadgets you can use but I
cannot overstate enough how much fun the
zip line is to use particular when your
zip lining between skyscrapers yeah it's
pretty fun how many do you get can you
just employ like three at once and then
be like oh oh god I can't remember if
there's like yeah actually I think you
do get a finite number per spawn so you
can't go totally buck wild with them
alright what it is well this concluded
obviously with the announcement that the
pc and ps4 beta for hard line is live
right now making make me for maybe the
first time jealous that I'm not that i
am wishing i was not at e3 so i could
play that thing it'll be really fun but
let's talk about the whole press
conference let's just sort of run it
down how did EA do on the whole what
kind of highlights lowlights what was
your overall impression it felt pretty
timid to me I would have liked to see
more just full gameplay like we saw with
battlefield hardline obviously they were
banking on that as being a surprise and
didn't really adjust their conference to
account for its league but you know it
was nice to see more of Mirror's Edge
more battlefront but it just wasn't
enough of them okay yeah it seems like
they kind of announced a few games too
soon a year ago and they had no choice
but to do something for them this year
even if they didn't have like gameplay
in a state they're ready to show it yet
so they did these studio tour
documentary kind of things with little
snippets of gameplay yeah which for us
people who just spent like 90 minutes we
watching all game playing the microsoft
press conference was a little bit
disappointing but there's definitely
some cool stuff in there mm-hmm I thank
Kevin well I said this on Twitter but I
think it bears
that I think that EA spent a whole lot
of time using words to say really almost
nothing at all and that was that was
really my takeaway is that they
basically just spent at times in blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah without
actually communicating yeah I think that
it was a sorry I'm just getting the news
that people are actually having trouble
downloading the hardline beta on PSN
surprise surprise but you know stick
with it and keep us posted because we
want to know what's up and we'll be
keeping you guys posted as well it was a
lot of talk and it did there was a lot
of stuff that was conceptual it almost
felt like why did you do a press
conference this year was it just to sell
hard line there was a lot of sports as
well you know what's your not that or
was yeah so changeable right i mean
every year yeah you know I've say like
me you know this was as much maybe for
like company morale or shareholders that
it was you know for a consumer because
sure like you know I I knew there were
some aspects upcoming need Daniel a
little bit of mass effect at me but it's
not substantive and especially held up
against the great mike microsoft press
conference you know it doesn't compare
super favorably but man that hardline
demo ya know that game super fun I I
played a couple hours of multiplayer I
really liked it and I wish that I had a
pc I could play the beta on right now in
LA but again maybe we'll try to get one
of these video editing pcs maybe yeah
don't need to watch breakouts of all
that stuff do you we are very well
socked in with breaking up these press
conferences so in case you guys missed
any of the trailers any of the
presentations you can find them up on
gamespot throughout the day we've been
posting them as well as our impressions
on the trailers themselves so keep an
eye out for that in one hour at 2 30
pacific time our pre-show for the
ubisoft press conference kicks off it
will be good running through all the
games we expect to see their what we're
hoping any long shots we want to see and
what Ubisoft needs to do to have a great
showing and maybe even outclass EA all
right gentlemen thank you so much for
sitting in here kevin van or dan hines
Sean McGuinness I'm Chris waters will be
here all three for you folks to come
back and join us in an hour for Ubisoft
see you then